tara good morning how are we doing well
i have a mentally handicapped brother
who lives in a small group home
and normally he works in a workshop
situation
and so he gets out daily but during
covet that's been
very few and far between times and and
right now
um they are closed again at his home
um currently he can't have anyone that
comes in to visit
and he can't go out anywhere to visit um
and he's gone from calling me because
i'm 350 miles away
but he's gone from calling me almost
daily um
and talking um to never calling
unless i initiate it and when i do call
him he just will absolutely not
communicate at all i just listen to him
breathe
um he's struggled with depression you
know but it's just
totally shut him down now and and i just
i don't know what i can do to help him
and and that's kind of why i'm calling
you is ideas on what i can do to help
him
um during this time with his situation
wow thank you for your call thank you
for your trust there
and i appreciate you being somebody who
loves their brother
um absolutely both because of and in
spite of his challenges that he's got so
what's the nature of his
special needs well he's mentally
handicapped
um i would put him maybe you know at
third fourth grade level
as far as you know his communication
skills and that kind of thing he
he is a physically very good i mean he
over the years
he's 55 now so over the years he's bold
he's played tennis special olympics
he loves video games he's very good at
him he's good at
card games um you know
horseback riding he loves that kind of a
thing um
he's never been a big talker but you
know he will get on a tangent
and talk and chat about you know his
bowling game and his tennis and things
like that and it's difficult now because
he has nothing to talk about that's
you know i can i can feel his pain there
you know that
he has nothing to talk about you know
does he does he have a full grasp of
what's going on
or is he you know if he's at a third
fourth fifth grade level
is he wrestling with this as most third
fourth and fifth graders are which is
suddenly their world
shifted underneath them and they get it
intellectually right they'll hear that
we're not going to be able to go to work
today or go to school today
but that's not appeasing their hearts is
he getting it or is he just struggling
i think he struggles with that i think
he's been told and they try to you know
make it
with all of them in the house you know
to try to explain but if i were guessing
and i don't know this for positive
he feels like he's done something wrong
probably you know
yep absolutely yeah i've heard that same
conversation
across the country that folks with
special needs
and folks under the age of middle school
are internalizing what's happened over
the past year
as something they've done if they would
have just been a little nicer or kinder
or washed their hands then this wouldn't
have all happened
and um that's that's just a whole
other devastating psychological
consequence of what we've been doing
here
so um he lives 350 miles away
and have you tried face timing him have
you tried any other
technological communication other than
just the phone call
right yeah we have done face timing um
and
and it was working okay like maybe
april may-ish and now he's gotten to
where he doesn't want to do that
i'm struggling with getting him to
charge his devices
um because i'll try to call him on his
cell phone or on facetime and
you know it's not charged and you know
i've been trying to work with the house
people on making sure that's done but um
struggling with just getting that
communication there to him
um and and you know the last time we
faced time you know he just he just
struggled with even lifting the ipad and
you know seeing me and me seeing him
so have you ever seen him go through a
pretty significant depressive episode
nothing like this okay are they at the
home are they getting
getting the the residents out and taking
them for walks getting them out
outside i don't think they're going for
walks they might put them in a van and
and drive them around
and i've been told that he doesn't want
to even do that he wants to sleep
sure yeah um so it's been my experience
with
adults with special needs that as much
as the rest of us
but in a in a very pointed and unique
way
the ability to work makes
a it brings an esteem that can only be
achieved through
accomplishment and work right and being
able to go somewhere with purpose
and go somewhere and accomplish
something
is a major driver of self-efficacy
that's i'm talking like an idiot here is
a major driver of self-esteem for
adults with special needs and when that
gets taken away
that when when you take away somebody's
purpose when you take away somebody's
well-being
that's just devastating right mike rowe
of
the dirty jobs fame was here in the
ramsey building a few months ago
and he he just off-handedly dropped a
line while he was talking and it is
stuck with me
he said when coveted broke out and we
determined there was essential and
non-essential workers
you know we said essential workers were
media personalities and
nurses and teachers things like that he
said inadvertently we told 300 plus
million americans you're not essential
just go home
we'll mail you a check and i had never
thought of it that way but we have just
told people
across the country eh we don't need you
go on home and we'll let you know when
you can come out
and it's been devastating and i just
my empathy for your brothers is is heavy
on my heart right now
because for somebody who can't
understand and is just being told stay
here stay here stay here
the the him withering underneath himself
is is to be expected right and it's and
it's heartbreaking
so a couple of things you can do number
one i would call the home
and with like all the kindness
yet forcefulness you can muster
i would strongly recommend they get
folks out to take walks
and whether that is a you can give him
some sort of
exercise program that quote unquote
becomes his job
or give him some set of goals that he
can accomplish by walking around the
neighborhood
whether that's giving him one of those
really cheap fitbits that he can count
steps what we want to do is little wins
we want to do little tiny what i would
call micro accomplishments
micro goals for him that are gonna both
get him
a sense of purpose but also get him
outside and get him sunshine
and get him moving around and if he's in
texas there then
the sunshine's gonna still be on him and
it'll be cool but it won't be freezing
and that would be a gift to him both
both
physiologically right the vitamin d and
the in the fresh air and all that and if
he's doing it with a community that will
help too
but it also is going to give him a sense
of purpose that has been taken away from
him because he can't go to work
another thought would be would he be
able to play
and kind of leave man talk about twist
of fate here i'm recommending this on
on my show would he be willing to play
video games with you
yeah i think he would i if you
challenged him and kind of talked it up
like talk some trash some good brother
sister trash and just
say hey i've been thinking and i'm ready
to dominate you in some
um video game that y'all could add so
yeah that might be a possibility
you could get one even and i can't i'm
telling you this man i'm always telling
people to get off the screens but this
may be one of those unique moments where
getting one of those
uh microphones and you do your best
trash talking sister you can
to get him out of his shell and give him
something to look forward to
and this would be a moment of
accountability for you if you put
something on the calendar for him a
couple of days a week and said on
tuesdays
at six o'clock prepare for big sis to
crush you
right and get him right and and get him
fired up that way
if he would do that and engage with you
there that would be a unique way that
you all could get connected and it may
be a way that he could get connected
with your kids if you've got them
with your spouse with other people in
the family too and again you're giving
him a sense of purpose you're giving him
something on the calendar to look
forward to
um and then i think it's really
important for you to recognize this
unique moment and that total
heartbreaking powerlessness
and you are such a great sister you're
focused on how you can help him
but i also don't want you to miss this
moment where you're gonna have to look
in the mirror
and exhale a little bit and drop your
shoulders and realize
how limited your personal power is right
have you experienced that have you gone
through your own grief on this deal
yeah i think so i think it's gotten more
and more here at
you know with things going up and them
closing again and the hope of them
reopening
you know they're telling us january and
i'm like you know that's a long
haul yeah it really is it's and it's a
long dark hall right
it's it's the winter months are not good
to be
pegged in and locked in is there a way
he could come visit you or is that a
no-no
yeah they won't allow it see he was
going to my parents house
every wednesday and playing games and
eating dinner and
they have not allowed that since like
february
wow wow yeah it looks like you're gonna
have to do the limited things you can
to lean in here and again i i would love
some sort of fitness
regimen and
the best i've been able to read and i've
tried to keep up with the science of
what's going on as much as possible
getting outside and going for walks is
not only
not going to contribute but it's going
to help folks
particularly the vitamin d side and the
good breath side
and number two if you can plug in and
play some video games there
but i don't want you to miss the
opportunity to get in touch with
yourself
because this just sucks and i want you
to spend a couple of minutes
mourning what you can control and what
you can't
i want you to spend a few moments on the
regular talking to somebody that you
care about and just
being able to express
i hate this i hate this
and this isn't whining this isn't
complaining this is just acknowledging
so many of us are just running into
solving mode solving mode and
man we just have to pause for a minute
and just own
it's no good man i hate this so tara i
think for the call i wish i could give
you
more concrete like hey just do this and
this and this and i'm guessing here
right
i'm guessing here um my hope is that you
can
use your the love and care you've got
for this young man
and get him plugged into some video
games i think that'd be a lot of fun
and man whenever i think i can't get
weirder james here i am on the show
recommending people play video games but
um tara thank you so much for that call